Canned messages may also be used to shortcut typing out a standard response.
This can save the agent typing time...
...but also saves the agent having to check details themselves...
...and reduces the risk of error.
Can you tell me how much your standard packages cost?
Packages range from 39 dollars a month to 59 dollars a month...
...depending on a couple of variables like how many users you require...
...and which features you need.
How many staff do you have?
Using a canned response in this scenario made the interaction quicker...
...and also eliminated the chance of making an error.
Remember to be selective in your use of canned responses.
Don't use them automatically.
Use them selectively when appropriate for the situation.